I just love the fact that we've gotten
used to all of these dudes in the oceans
movies and this one's all women who's do
you think would be better the godmother
[Music]
all-time favorite heist films
oh so many god I love it when people
steal stuff I get so many ideas I love
out of sight is that George Clooney JLo
with a nightstick
it taught me mostly that there are a lot
of different places you can meet suitors
including the back of someone's trunk
yeah me personally uh Spike Lee's Inside
Man I honestly think that it was his
best movie since like do the right thing
in Malcolm X I've Owen just pulling the
wool over everyone's eyes I love a lot
of them but sneakers is probably like
tops because I mean Robert Redford
Sydney obviously great Impossibles I
love those also missions impossible
missions impossible missions and yeah
and Lock Stock and Two Smoking Barrels
honest with God that's my favor also die
hard it is a heist movie because most of
these heist movies the protagonist is
the one who's stealing something in this
one the antagonist Hans Gruber is
pulling off the heist
and I would have gotten away with it if
it hadn't been for John I also love
Jackie Brown oh yes that cast is so
crazy and that's what really reminds me
of ocean's 8 is like all of these great
people that I want to see stealing
things I just want to hold on a job make
some friends it's a gender bent version
of
Ocean's eleven franchise we have Sandra
Bullock playing Danny ocean sister I
like that
I just love the fact that we've gotten
used to all of these dudes in the oceans
movies and this one's all women yeah do
you think would be better oh I mean so
many the godmother massacred my girl a
matriarchal mafia family oh yeah awesome
you're breaking my heart
and also my mail I'm more of the opinion
that there are some movies that just
don't blend well like no offense I don't
want to see the all-female Fight Club
I just don't oh come on stop pretending
you're not inherently violent like the
rest of us I think that Magic Mike would
be better if it was all ladies feeling
every movie that ever has yes
we're some of your favorite moments from
the original Ocean's eleven I love how
funny they are I loved Elliott Gould
sitting by a pool wearing lots of gold
yeah we wrote some glasses do you like
how many people are in this thing cuz I
generally like the love actually's of
the world I think they're fun it seems
like they were having fun I feel like
when I watch one of these movies I get a
lot for my money's worth yeah you know
so it's like not just one star it's like
eighty five stars yeah and honestly the
first Ocean's eleven you have someone
like Don she don't kind of slum in it
and his fifth you know leading man role
behind everyone else and he's hilarious
the awful cockney accent that he does
beyond it is right up there with Mary
Poppins wears clothes I love the
original original the OG Ocean's eleven
with yeah with the Rat Pack it was
awesome and the fact that they don't get
the money at the end of my favorite
things there are kids watching this you
don't know what
seventy years later if if you didn't
know now you know
also Soderbergh who's kind of like the
king of this yeah and he did the oceans
franchise and he went and did Logan
lucky which I feel like was his version
of changing it you know called it ocean
7-eleven it didn't fare as well at the
box office but people really liked it
which I don't understand cuz the heist
was super complicated the guys were
really funny great cast again Adam
driver Channing Tatum that movie was
awesome
there's so many great characters to
choose from and oceans eight who do you
want on your crew I mean Brianna in all
things I want Rihanna I just I love her
and like she's just amazing I definitely
want to have Cate Blanchett and Helena
bonham-carter because they are not from
around here
and so they are just automatically more
sophisticated was Thor Ragnarok she just
does what she wants doesn't she go to
Carroll Thor and now she's gonna be iced
ended up with sandy I'm so pumped about
Sarah Paulsen in this movie because I
think she's exactly the woman that you
would never suspect I am with my family
I told him and she's doing the Michael
Corleone in The Godfather Part three
thing Mike I just got out and they're
pulling me back and I get pulled into
this underworld and of course she's
gonna be there just like Carl Reiner in
the first is it genetic or the whole
family like this literally I'm excited
to see why George Clooney and Sandra
Bullock's character are estranged
because apparently there's a reason for
that yeah they're both degenerate
thieves so of course they're fighting
yeah or maybe she dated rusty Danny
ocean's right-hand man Wow yeah and
maybe that like went sideways in three
and a half weeks and that will be
hosting its annual ball I'm so excited
for this movie for one reason especially
the cameos they're filming it at the Met
Gala tons of celebrities are gonna be
put into it can't we just go to this
debate to steal stuff yes who are you
hoping to maybe see it bring some new
blood in there bring Steve Guttenberg
you know honestly I think my boy Timothy
sha'lame is gonna make his first if
Madonna was there yeah I would be like
girl this is the best movie you've been
involved with in ages I love it I have a
plan that I'd like to unfold because
they hate a plan I love the plan making
I love heist films like a little bit too
much I noticed that
Jonathan brings in this glorious yogurt
when we shoot if I was going to take it
this is how I would do it every perfect
heist has a perfect distraction right so
I'm going to be using my super sleuthing
skills I would obtain Jonathan's phone
number okay not that hard he's gonna get
a call from who he thinks is
casting agent who's all like Oh callback
and Jonathan's like yay don't know what
happened though it has to be from the
agent I love work shopping this that's
when I would make my move when he's all
busy being like why am I getting called
by a casting agent where's my where's my
agent incognito
I would escape totally unnoticed and
then I would get to enjoy the creamy
goodness of the stolen yogurt and I am
victorious I would watch that
I mean be like five minutes long but I
would watch it oh my phone's ringing
that's weird cuz we were just talking
about this but oh hi agent movie trivia
time this time heist movies come in I'm
gonna steal this one alright first which
heist film takes place at the fame
Nakatomi Plaza let's go which of these
heist films were based on true events
exchange operation fast and furious was
pitched as blank but with cars West Side
Story were just kidding now Isis oh my
god West Side Story is a joke alright
which franchise pulled off the biggest
heist means though I assume cartoon
because then they could do whatever they
want what the neuro film Falls criminal
Neil McCauley it didn't seem like that
was known an awesome time with you
ladies talking about heist movies it was
awesome there's not enough film in these
cameras to talk more they'll go CEO
should say it's gonna be great
definitely pick up your tickets over at
finding go calm there's steel
[Music]
you